bonjour à tous alors cette semaine est
une semaine très internationale pour le
président nicolas sarkozy et les
républicains puisque nous aurons
mercredi ici rue de vaugirard une
matinée de travail consacré aux
questions de politique étrangère aux
affaires internationales qui se conclura
à midi par un discours du président et
puis parallèlement à l'assemblée
nationale autour de christian jacob
nous organisons une réunion du club des
28 c'est le club des présidents des
groupes parlementaires nationaux qui
sont inscrits au ppe et cette journée de
travail à l'assemblée sera consacrée le
matin aux questions d'immigration
l'après midi aux questions de terrorisme
nicolas sarkozy comme président des
républicains ouvrira cette réunion
christian jacob la présidera et votre
serviteur d'ailleurs animera les deux
tables rondes celle du matin et celle de
l'après midi sur l'immigration et sur le
terroriste assez pour le mercredi 15
juin
le lendemain nicolas sarkozy sera à
saint pétersbourg
vous en avez conclu puisque vous avez un
esprit de déduction très puissant qu'il
prendra donc l'avion dans la nuit à
saint pétersbourg donc il participera au
forum économique international de saint
pétersbourg
voilà pour eux pour l'agenda un mot 7/3
vous le savez la dernière des élections
législatives partielles puisque nous
entrons maintenant dans l'année qui nous
sépare de la prochaines élections
générales législatives
nous nous réjouissons du succès massif
de stéphanie pernaut beau donc et donc
nouvelle députée les républicains de la
3e circonscription de l'ain avec 73% des
suffrages exprimés elle s'impose contre
le candidat qui avait des qualifiés pour
le second tour candidat soutenu par
madame le pen
vous vous souvenez que le parti
socialiste avait été éliminé dès le
premier tour alors que 3par avant il
était présent au second tour il ya bien
calmes un sens politique cela les
électeurs ont voulu sanctionner le
pouvoir en place
exprimé leur confiance dans les
républicains qui préparent l'alternance
avant que philippe juvin évoque de très
nombreux sujets de deux points de fond
si vous le voulez bien d'abord les
incidents de marseille mais aussi de
nice
il est temps que bernard cazeneuve le
ministre de l'intérieur sortent du déni
l'ordre public n'a pas était respecté à
marseille ce week-end il y avait
manifestement des dysfonctionnements des
failles dans le dispositif de sécurité
et le ministre de l'intérieur à tort
d'afficher une forme d'autosatisfaction
qui n'a pas lieu d'être
il ya eu des failles dans le dispositif
de sécurisation de ce match de l'euro à
marseille et nous posons des questions
extrêmement précises auxquelles nous
demandons au ministre de l'intérieur de
répondre de manière précise première
question pourquoi les hooligans russe ou
anglais n'ont ils pas était identifié
ciblées et mis hors d'état de nuire en
amont cette question vous le comprenez
bien pose celle de la coopération entre
les services de police français et leurs
homologues étrangers deuxième question
pourquoi des ventes d'alcool ont pu être
autorisés ou plus exactement non pas
être interdite non seulement aux abords
immédiats du stade vélodrome mais aussi
plus en plus largement dans le périmètre
de déplacement des supporteurs troisième
question encore plus préoccupante pour
quoi
des engins incendiaires et notamment une
ou plusieurs bombes agricoles ont pu
être introduite à l'intérieur du
périmètre du stade vélodrome
c'est une question particulièrement
sérieuse chacun a pu entendre en
regardant à la télévision le match
une explosion probablement celle d'un
engin qu'on appelle une bombe agricole
faut que le gouvernement s'explique
comment une bombe agricole peut-elle
être introduites à l'intérieur du stade
vélodrome
quatrième et dernière question technique
pourquoi le dispositif de gestion des
supporteurs à l'intérieur du stade
n'at-il pas permis l'étanchéité entre la
zone russe et la zone anglaise on a vu
des mouvements de foule s'opérait au
risque de bousculer des supporteurs des
familles voire même des rangs mêmes des
enfants
à ces quatre questions techniques très
précise il faut que le ministre de
l'intérieur assume d'apporter des
réponses
j'ajoute que les déclarations
lénifiantes du préfet de police de
marseille qui explique que tout va bien
rappel les déclarations lénifiantes du
même préfet lorsqu'il était directeur de
cabinet du préfet de police à paris et
que sur l'esplanade des invalides
il y avait eu d incident absolument
intolérable donc on a besoin à la fois
de professionnalisme dans la chaîne de
commandement et d'esprit de
responsabilité
j'ajoute pour en terminer que nous
vivons toujours sous l' empire de l'état
d'urgence l'état d'urgence n'a plus
aucun sens si des scènes de guérilla
urbaine peuvent se dérouler en toute
impunité dans les rues de la deuxième
ville de france
ce
point d'actualité sur un sujet très
différents l'éducation nationale nous
appelons najat vallaud belkacem la
ministre de l'éducation nationale à
cesser immédiatement ces mesures de
déconstruction de l'éducation nationale
qui sont aujourd'hui engagés il y en a
deux sur lesquels je voudrais appeler
l'attention ce matin la première mesure
totalement absurde consisterait pour le
ministère de l'éducation nationale à
verser une prime
en réalité de 600 à 1000 euros à des
élèves décrocheurs c'est-à-dire des
élèves qui entre 16 et 18 ans sèche les
cours pendant cinq mois et reviennent
dans leur établissement
c'est un dispositif absolument absurde
qui consiste en réalité à encourager
paradoxalement l'absentéisme c'est très
cohérent avec les mesures que najat
vallaud belkacem avait prises ou tenter
de prendre au cours du quinquennat on se
souvient que le gouvernement de jean
marc ayrault avait souhaité supprimer
les bourses au mérite
in fine est elles ont été réduites de
moitié diminution de moitié des bourses
mérite mais création d'une prime aux
décrocheurs tout ça est encore une fois
totalement absurde il faut remettre ce
ministère à l'endroit et c c'est
d'imaginer des mesures aussi
contre-productive aussi peu conforme à
l'intérêt général deuxième problème
immédiat s'agissant du ministère de
l'éducation nationale
nous sommes très préoccupés par
l'annoncé d'une modification du régime
des enseignements hors contrat permettez
que je prenne quelques instants pour eux
développer l'état du droit
est ce que compte faire le ministre de
l'éducation nationale l'état du droit
aujourd'hui c'est un régime au fond de
liberté sous contrôle pour ouvrir une
école hors contrat
il faut faire une déclaration et cette
déclaration permet à l'administration de
connaître l'existence de cette école
hors contrat et ensuite de procéder à
des contrôles contrôle sur les
enseignements qui sont dispensés
contrôle aussi sur tous les éléments qui
tiennent à l'ordre public et l'état
les administrations les pouvoirs publics
ont dans ce cadre dans le cadre de la
loi et des décrets actuelle le pouvoir
et même le devoir de fermer des écoles
hors contrat qui méconnaîtraient les
exigences pédagogiques ou qui
troublerait l'ordre public tout ça est
complètement caresser prévues notamment
à l'article 227-17 tirer 1 du code pénal
qui a été modifié en dernier lieu par un
décret du 5 janvier 2012 sous le
quinquennat précédent
on a bien un régime qui est à la fois un
régime de liberté qui respecte l'école
libre qui respecte le droit des
françaises et des français à créer les
conditions d'un enseignement libre hors
contrat avec l'éducation nationale
mais un régime de contrôle pour
s'assurer qu'au plan pédagogique et aux
plans de l'ordre public
les choses sont carrées si j'ose dire
najat vallaud belkacem envisage de
supprimer ce régime de liberté pour le
remplacer par un régime d'autorisation
ex ante et d'autorisation préalable
nous y voyons une atteinte très forte à
la liberté d'enseignement et nous sommes
donc tout à fait hostile à cette
modification nous y voyons une attaque
contre l'école libre et nous demandons
donc aujourd'hui au nom des républicains
à najat vallaud belkacem de retirer ce
projet qui nous paraît encore une fois
contraire à l'exigence de liberté à
l'exigence de respect des libertés de
liberté de l'éducation de liberté aussi
des des consciences j'ajoute d'ailleurs
que si un tel débat devait avoir lieu il
aurait nécessairement lieu de notre
point de vue devant le parlement
à supposer que le gouvernement veuille
modifier le régime des écoles libres
qu'il faudrait qu'ils viennent s'en
expliquer devant le parlement qui
procèdent pas par décret de manière
subreptice est en tout cas de manière
peu visible dans un débat public ce
débat public nous sommes prêts à
l'assumer nous l'appelons nos voeux
cette modification juridique est trop
importante pour qu'elle passe comme ça
par un simple décret est pris en
catimini
il faut un vrai débat nous sommes nous
défenseurs de la liberté d'enseignement
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
introduction maintenant philippe juvin
député français au parlement européen et
maire de villeneuve-la-garenne va
s'exprimer
merci beaucoup de philippe juvin maire
de la garenne colombes ça n'a rien à
voir avec villeneuve la garenne sont
deux cons de contrer de contrer tout à
fait tout à fait sympathique
tout d'abord en matière de l'actualité
internationale il ya évidemment la
l'attentât d' orlando qui a fait comme
vous le savez au moins 50 morts des
dizaines de blessés
le président nicolas sarkozy au nom des
républicains a exprimé dans un
communiqué de presse sa profonde
tristesse et son entière solidarité avec
le peuple américain
par ailleurs nous voulons aussi dire que
les républicains ont toujours été à la
pointe de la lutte contre l'homophobie
et
il ne faut pas évidemment se cacher se
voiler la face
l'attentât de cette nuit est un attentat
aussi contre une communauté qui est la
communauté homosexuelle et attaquer et
tuer quelqu'un et les persécutés en
fonction de l'orientation sexuelle est
évidemment d'autant plus d'autant plus
intolérable au fond on savait que l'
état islamique sur place dans les
territoires qui le contrôlent
s'attaquait très largement et d'une
manière continuelle aux homosexuels il y
a malheureusement un continuum qui
montre toute la barbarie de cette
organisation
j'ajoute que cette organisation qui a
revendiqué l'attentât
est ce une revendication d'opportunités
en tout cas la revendication est
présente et c'est ça le plus important
qualifie souvent les victimes venant de
ses propres troupes qui meurt dans ces
opérations de martyres et nous nous
retiendrons la remarque qui avait été
fait à l'époque par monseigneur lustiger
qui considérait que cette définition de
martyrs était évidemment une définition
qui étaient totalement fausses
un martyr pour nous c'est quelqu'un qui
donne sa vie pour les autres
or là on a des exemples au contraire de
gens qui donnent leur vie pour tuer
d'autres personnes
on est à mille lieues de ce principe de
cette définition qui nous paraît être la
bonne sur les questions internationales
il y a cette déclaration a eu récentes
du président turc d'une très grande
menace vis-à-vis de collègues députés
allemands au bundestag et que les
républicains condamne absolument vous
souvenez que le bundestag de juin a voté
une résolution qui a reconnu le génocide
arménien ce qui a conduit ankara à une
terrible colère et monsieur erdogan
s'est attaqué aux députés allemands
d'origine turque en les accusant d'être
des traîtres à leur pays ceci sans je le
rappelle député allemand au bundestag
élu par le démocratiquement par le
peuple allemand il les a accusés je cite
d'être d'avoir le sens corrompu et il a
appelé à la nécessité de leur donner
ouvrez les guillemets la leçon qu'il
mérite
les accusés pour avoir accusé ouvrez les
guillemets leur propre pays de génocide
et donc on voit bien combien il est
impossible d'avoir un débat sur des
bases démocratiques normale avec un chef
d'état qui met en cause un certain
nombre de représentants du peuple
allemand librement désigné deuxième
observation il s'agit également d'une
observation qui nous vient d'allemagne
et il vous intéressera peut-être de
connaître que l'institut allemand de
recherche économique et sociale
je ne vous fais pas en allemand le
deutsches titou furent wirth je ne sais
plus quoi le diy w a publié une étude
assez intéressante qui a travaillé le
nombre qui a piqué le nombre annuel de
jours de grève pour 1000 salariés entre
mille 2005 et 2014
malheureusement la france arrive en tête
avec 132 jours en france 124 jours au
danemark 84 en belgique
63 en espagne 23 royaume uni 15 en
allemagne et donc on voit bien toute la
difficulté de de l'utilisation politique
qui est faite de la grève
et comme vous le savez le président
sarkozy a très clairement dit la semaine
dernière qu'il faudrait tirer un certain
nombre de leçons des grèves actuelles en
étendant des éléments de service minimum
et cette étude de cet observatoire
allemand est là pour montrer cette très
grande asymétrique il y as entre notre
pays et ses voisins 132 jours de grève
en france pour 15 en allemagne / sur 9
années
troisième observation le président
landes multiplie les commémorations
depuis quelques jours on le voit un peu
partout y compris à colombey les deux
églises alors d'une certaine manière
nous nous félicitons de ce qui pourrait
être une sorte de conversion tardive à
quelques valeurs que qui sont les nôtres
et valeur le gaullisme
même si nous ne faisons ne nous faisons
aucune illusion bien sûr sur le
caractère
tactique d'une telle multiplication de
commémoration à tel point qu'on se
demande si les présidents de la vème
république ou de la quatrième puisque
comme vous le savez le président de la
4è allait de commémoration en
inauguration ce que semble faire
actuellement le président hollande deux
points très rapide sur une actualité
purement européenne alors là c'est un
petit peu moins sexy je suis désolé
c'est le parlement européen sommes des
gens très sérieux qui veut ce sont des
textes parfois très difficilement
compréhensible vous avez appris des
beaucoup d'acronymes l'année dernière le
taf talent il y en à nouveau qu'il faut
que vous appreniez maintenant ce nous
l'avons appris aussi c'est la tap
à thé ap à thé apc paquet anti taxe void
ans anti taxe veille de ce paquet
il s'agit d'une série de mesures qui
visent au fond à mettre fin à ce qu'on
appelle l'évitement fiscal des
entreprises c'est-à-dire toutes les
stratégies qui permettent de ne pas
payer d'impôts et donc le parlement
européen a adopté un promu une première
directive c'est à dire une loi
européenne qui va maintenant être
discuté au conseil avec deux buts
principaux premièrement faire en sorte
que les entreprises paient leurs impôts
là où elle réalise des bénéfices et
deuxièmement rédiger une définition
commune des paradis fiscaux donc c'est
un texte qui a été porté par le ppe
soutenue évidemment par lui et je vous
rappelle que l'évitement fiscal des
entreprises c'est une perte de 160 à 190
milliards d'euros par an dans l'union
européenne
évidemment quelque chose de considérable
enfin je terminerai avec une autre
actualité européenne législatives qui en
fait a une connotation française très
forte
c'est la question du glyphosate gl y ph
os ats c'est le round up
de quoi s'agit-il en fait l'utilisation
du roundup et est autorisé en europe
jusqu'à la fin de ce mois ci à la fin de
ce mois une nouvelle autorisation n'est
pas donné eh bien le roundup est
désormais définitivement exclus de toute
l'union européenne
la difficulté c'est que le roundup est
indispensable aux agriculteurs qui n'ont
pas d'alternative aujourd'hui est donc
la commission européenne a souhaité il
ya quelques mois ré autoriser leur en
donne pour 15 années nous nous sommes
opposés au parlement européen les
députés du ppe des républicains mais
aussi les socialistes français nous
sommes alliés pour proposer une
réintroduction du roundup beaucoup plus
courte cette année avec des études qui
ponctuent ray les sept ans et surtout
l'interdiction d'utiliser le roundup à
des fins domestiques us uniquement le
réserver aux agriculteurs qui encore une
fois non pas d'alternative et il y à des
études très contradictoires sur la
toxicité du roundup études qui disent
que c'est très toxique d'autres qui
disent que ça ne l'est pas et des
instituts aussi sérieux les uns que les
autres et donc là-dessus madame royal a
pris la parole en disant c'est
scandaleux
l'europe veut rétablir veut réautoriser
le roundup moi je m'y oppose bien on a
observé qu'en fait à une réunion où les
représentants des états présents étaient
présents madame royal ne s'est pas
opposée au roundup
alors qu'elle dit dans la presse qu'elle
s'y opposait ne s'est pas opposée elle
s'est contentée de s'abstenir
l'idée quoi l idée est simple c'est que
elle souhaite au fond que l'europe
portent cette responsabilité ne veut pas
dire non pourquoi elle ne veut pas dire
non elle ne veut pas dire non parce que
monsieur le foll et pour donc on a une
situation absolument abracadabrantesque
d'un côté les députés socialistes
européens disent il faut que le roundup
sont autorisés parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'alternative
là pour le coup ils sont sérieux ils
sont comme nous madame royal
cris dans les gazettes qu'elle ne veut
pas de roundup mais monsieur le seul le
foll en veut et donc il finit la france
n'a pas de position
quand la commission européenne demande à
la france qu'elle en pense au comité
technique du 6 juin
eh bien la france est abstenu on ne sait
pas ce que la france veut la réalité
aussi des choses c'est que elle veut
faire porter à la seule commission phare
de peu le fardeau politique d'une re
circulation du produit et nous voulons
simplement mettre madame royal devant
ses responsabilités ça a été dit par le
commissaire à la santé
il a dit les états membres n'ont pas
besoin de se cacher derrière une
décision de la commission pour autoriser
ou non la commercialisation du
glyphosate
donc nous disons très simplement habana
mme royal que nous nous avons pris nos
responsabilités nous voulons interdire
pour les usages domestiques
nous voulons réglementée avec des
conditions d'utilisation traces tic pour
les usages professionnels mais
aujourd'hui nous observons que les
agriculteurs n'ont pas d'alternative et
madame royal elle veut l'interdire eh
bien écoutez qu'elle prenne ses
responsabilités mais il faudra qu'elle
s'explique auprès des agriculteurs en
tout cas il n'est pas normal qu'un
ministre de la république ne sache pas
faire prendre à la france une position
dans un sujet aussi important la
politique c'est aussi savoir prendre les
décisions y compris quand elles sont un
peu compliqué à prendre
voilà j'en ai terminé sur l'actualité
européano internationale et nous sommes
prêts à répondre à vos questions